اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
وسط مخاوف اوكرانيه من الانتقام من روسي
كبير بريطانيا تحذر من هجمات متطوره
السلطات الاثريه تنصح مواطنيها بعدم السفر
الى ايران بعد الهجوم على سفارتها في
طهران
التزام امريكي يتجدد في سول بالدفاع عن
كوريا الجنوبيه بالاسلحه التقليديه
السلطات الباكستانيه تعلن ارتفاع حصيله
قتل التفجير الانتحاري بمسجد في بشاور الى
ثلاث وتسعين
البدايه من تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث
اعلن القائم باعمال رئيس
بوشولين عن تقدم القوات الروسيه بالرغم من
تعزيز المواقع الاوكرانيه في اراضي
المنشات الصناعيه وعلى طول خط المواجهه
وشيرين قال ايضا ان الاوضاع الاوكرانيه
الراهنه تزداد الصعوبه لان الخسائر
الفادحه في صفوفها لا يشكل اهميه للقياده
لاصدار الاوامر بالتراجع كما اضاف ايضا ان
القوات الروسيه
اقدامها في مدينه فوريكار ومن جانبه اوضح
مستشار موشيلين ان القوات سيطره جزئيا على
طريق مؤذن الى بخموت
الاستخبارات البريطانيه مشاهدينا افادت
بان القوات الروسيه نفذت عمليات الهجوميه
على مدينتين بالفيسكا وفولدر ذلك خلال
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه مشيره الى
توقعاتها الى تطوير محور روسي جديد للتقدم
في دنيتك في الوقت الذي تقل فيها
الترجيحات او تقل من ان يكون لدى روسيا ما
يكفي من القوات لتحقيق عملياتها وزاره
الدفاع بدورها قالت في بلاروسيا ان
تدريبات عسكريه مشتركه بدات بالفعل مع
روسيا وتستمر اسبوعا وتشارك فيها القياده
المشتركه للقوات الاقليميه من الجانبين
وقالت الوزاره في بيان ان التدريبه هو جزء
من الاستعداد لمناورات العسكريه بين
البلدين تجري في سبتمبر المقبل
من دنيتكم معنا مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
اهلا بك معنا رائد اذا تطورات المعارك في
دونيتك حدثنا عنها حتى اللحظه
نحن على بعد اقل من شهر من الدخول في
العام الثاني من المعارك او الحروب هنا في
اوكرانيا نحن على بعد اقل من شهر من
المواجهه المنتظره ما بين الاليه العسكريه
الحديثه من قبل اوكرانيا او الغرب اذا صحت
تعبير ومن قبل روسيا حيث ادخلت روسيا
اليات عسكريه جديده من دبابات ومن مقاتلات
وكذلك من منصات صواريخ كذلك الغرب ارسال
دبابات حديثه ايضا همم مقاتلات امريكيه
ونحن على بعد ايام او اسابيع من المعركه
الكبرى او ام المعارك مثل ما وصفوها سابقا
في الشرق الاوكراني بالفعل القوات الروسيه
تزيد من امداداتها العسكريه كان البشريه
او بالاليه على كل المحاور كما ان الجيش
الاوكراني ايضا يدفع بمزيد من جنود حشود
كبيره على اطراف لمان وكبيانز كما ان هناك
حشود على اطراف زاباروجه اليوم قال
لميتريديم الراغوغوف المسؤول في السلطات
التابعه لروسيا في زاباروجي بان المناطق
التي سيطرت عليها روسيا واسست قواعد
عسكريه لها تقوم القوات الاوكرانيه في هي
المنطقه تدعى كامنز في المنطقه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه من زاباروجه همم القوات
الاوكرانيه ايضا تقوم بامدادات عسكريه
كبيره وبتاسيس قواعد عسكريه موازيه لها
بنقاط قريبه جدا وتنص يعني تنصب صواريخ
يقول بان الدفاع الروسيه مده همم
المقاتلين في الزبرج من الصوت صواريخ
تورناندو اس وهي اكثر فعاليه من هايبر نحن
على وشك يعني الدخول في مواجهات كبيره همم
معارك لا تنتهي المحور الشمالي ايضا حيث
همم باخموت ما زالت قوات فاتنر تسيطر على
مزيد من البلدات هناك تصريحات عن السيطره
عن اكثر من 25 بلده في مختلف انا وحي
دانيات طبعا القوات الاوكرانيه تنفي بانها
تنسحب من بعض البلدات بينما تقول قوات
فاجنر على سبيل المثال
بلاجاباتنا في المنطقه الشماليه قالت
بانها سيطرت على المنطقه وسطنا في اجانب
الاخراني».\‬»
الروس كثر تحدث عن هذه المعارك هل لك ان
تجمل لنا ابرز هذه التصريحات
التصريحات من ناحيه مدينه اوغلادار على
سبيل المثال دينيس بوشولين قال بان الجيش
الروسي بات يطوق المدينه من الناحيه
الجنوبيه ومن الناحيه الشرقيه والجنوبيه
الغربيه يعني دخلوا قليلا من الغرب وانهم
دخلوا الى اطراف المدينه من الناحيه
الجنوبيه دخلوا الى حد المناجم وتقدموا
لاربعه كيلومترات في الامام ودخلوا في عمق
المنجم كيلو مترين حيث تحصن القوات
الاوكرانيه تعليميه ان المنطقه مليئه
بالمناجم
والمناطق الصناعيه او المصانع دم باص
باكملها هي مشهوره بالمناجم والصناعات
فدخول احد المناجم هذا يعني بان معارك
تجري حتى تحت الارض في السراديب فاطمه
بالفعل القوات الروسيه تطوق المدينه
وتحاول اقتحامها من الناحيه الشرقيه ايضا
وتدخل اطراف المدينه هذا كله مع غطاء من
وقذف العنيف من المدفعيه الروسيه وكذلك
راجمات الصواريخ ملاحظه اخيره ان
المقاتلات الروسيه باتت حاضره في سماء
المنطقه باستمرار بشكل يومي صباحا ومساءا
شكرا
العربيه رائد الاخبار
الامير العام لحلف الناتوينز مشاهدينا قال
ان نجاح العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا سيشكل رساله خطيره للقاده
الاستبداديين في انحاء العالم
زياره القاعده روما العسكريه في اليابان
انه انتصار بوتين سيعكس للعالم مفهوم ان
استخدام القوه العسكريه ينتهي بتحقيق
الاهداف
اما الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قال ان
بلاده لن تزود اوكرانيا مقاتلات اف 160
لمساعدتها في التصدي للقوات الروسيه وردا
على سؤال صحفيين في البيت الابيض عما اذا
كان يؤيد ارسال هذه المقاتلات الى كييف
كما طلب منه ااه او طلب منه عدم من القاده
الاوكرانيين اجاب بيض النفي وفي كيب اكد
الرئيس الاوكراني
اكد ان القوات الروسيه تسعى الانتقام من
شديد من اوكرانيا كما اعلن الرئيس بان
جيشه يحضر له هجوم مضاد كبير ضد القوات
الروسيه
يا ابو الشوق اعتقد ان روسيا تريد حقنا
الانتقام منا بشده وقد بدا ذلك بالفعل
اعتقد انهم لن يكونوا قادرين على تحقيق اي
مكاسب ايجابيه لمجتمعهم وفيما يتعلق
بجيشنا فانه سيوقف تقدم القوات الروسيه
ويدمرها تدركيا ونحن نستعد لهجوم مضاد
شامل
في الحصول على مقاتلات اف 16 ما ابرز ردود
الفعل التي رصدتها في الداخل حتى الان
محمد
يعني حتى لو لحظه من المبكر الحديث عن
ردود فعل اوكرانيه حول يعني جواب الرئيس
الامريكي لاحد الصحفيين عن امكانيه تزويد
اوكرانيا في الوقت الحالي بطيران او
بمقاتلات اف 16 كان جوابه هناك ولكن يعني
ان تبعنا الامر مثل ما حصل مع دبابات
ابرام حيث من ثلاثه اسابيع كانت الاداره
الامريكيه والرئيس يرفضون تماما مجرد
الحديث عن دبابات ثقيله دبابات ابرامز
ولكن تغيرت الظروف ووافقت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على اعطاء اوكرانيا
طائره اف 16 كما حصل ايضا بالصابونه
منظومات
الدفاعيه الجويه لذلك يعني اصبح موضوع
الطائرات والسلاح الذي يريده الجيش
الاوكراني ويسوق له وكما قال وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني متريكوليبا ان معركه
الحصول على طائره اف 16 قدمت وهناك
اتصالات دوليه
وقد تم الخليه خاصه
لمفاوضات مع الدول الاوروبيه ودول حلف
الناتو خاصه ان هناك اربع دول حتى هذه
اللحظه رسميا اعلنت والاستعدادها لتزويد
اوكرانيا بطائرات اف 16 مثل هولندا مثل
همم بريطانيا مثل بولندا وتشيك هذه الدول
اكد بانها مستعده لتقدم طائرات ال16 الى
اوكرانيا وايضا فلاندا وعدت بتقديم حوالي
89 طائره 29 همم يعني هي سوفياتيه الصنع
وعدت بتقديمها خلال الفتره للجيش
الاوكراني كما وعدت هولندا بتزويد
اوكرانيا وتسليح لواء كامل من القوات
الاوكرانيه بشكل سريع تدريبه هو تسليحه مع
الاعداد خلال الفتره المقبله لذلك حتى هذه
اللحظه من الممكن
على هذه همم الدول لتزويد كيف في هذه
المقاتله طيب محمد ماذا عن المعارك حتى
الان حيث انت كيف تجري
نعم يعني في شرق اوكرانيا في منطقه
الاوكراني بدا يعد لحشق الكبير خاصه
وهي تحاول التقدم هناك معارك اخذ بين
طرفين تتقدم القوات الروسيه ثم تغير
القوات الاوكرانيه ما تتراجع القوات
الروسيه هذا في يعني قطاع زفروشه في منطقه
دار اما في محيط ضخمه تستمر القوات
الروسيه باعداد الحشد الكبير
لقواتها لاقتحام مدينه حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يتم الاقتحام القوات الاوكرانيه بدات
باعداد خطوط دفاعيه كبيره في تلك المنطقه
وايضا يمكن القول ان يعني القوات
الاوكرانيه تعد وكما قال الرئيس الاوكراني
تعد له هجوم كبير وشامل وربما سيكون في
بدايه او من بدايه الى منتصف شهر مارس
عندما القوات الاوكرانيه على العتاب
اللازم خاصه يعني مدرعات برادلي التي
اصبحت في طريقها الى اوكرانيا لا ساعات
قليله ستكون هذه يعني ناقلات الجوند
المتطوره مع الجيش الاوكراني وايضا هناك
امدادات عسكريه كبيره للقوات الاوكرانيه
بدا بالحصول عليها من بولندا من تشيكيا من
المانيا ومن سلوفاكيا والسلوفينيا وايضا
لاتفيا التي قدمت كل ما تمتلكه من اا
العتاب والسلاح والذخيره للجيش الاوكراني
واضح شكرا لك الصحفي محمد البابا
طيب نشير الى هذا العاجل امامنا على
الشاشه حيث يبدو ان رئيس وزراء هولندا
مشاهدينا يؤكد على ما تحدثنا عنه مع محمد
البابا قبل قليل بانه هولندا مستعده لبحث
تزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات بتنسيق مع الناتو
وعوده الى سياق نشرتنا حذرت اذربيجان
مواطنيها من السفر الى ايران الا للضروره
وذلك بعد الاعتداء على سفارتها في طهران
بطبيعه الحال ونصحت وزاره الخارجيه
الاذربيجانيه في بيان صحه المواطنين
الموجودين في ايران بمراعات قواعد السلامه
والامن واشار البيان ايضا الى الهجوم الذي
وقع على سفارتها في اذربيجان الجمعه
الماضيه واصفانيه بالهجوم الارهابي
الطائرات بدون طيار ارسلتها طهران الى
اليمن بايدي الحوثيين ولاعب الدوله
المحوريه في حرب الظل بين ايران واسرائيل
ومع ذلك من المفارقات ان مخاطرها كانت
اعلى داخل ايران نفسها
[موسيقى]
المسيرات الرخيصه سلاح ايران المفضل
ارسلتها طهران الى كل مكان حيث ميليشياتها
في سوريا والعراق واليمن ولعب دورا في حرب
الوكاله لتعظيم الموقف وتهديد الممرات
المائيه لتنفيذ مشروعا الخاص
المسيرات الانتحاريه التي تجمعها ايران
تستخدمها كورقه ضغط لتحقيق مكاسب في
المفاوضات النوويه او لرفع العقوبات
[موسيقى]
لطالما كان الغرب يفكر باليه للحد من سلوك
ايران ومسيراتها وما حدث في اصفهان كان
رساله لتغيير في الاستراتيجيه
مسيرات من داخل البلاد تضرب موقع عسكريا
هذه المره في ايران وجود خلايا واختراق
داخل ايران مساله تتصاعد حيث كان البرنامج
النووي الايراني هدفا لمحاولات تخريب
متكرره في عام 2020 اغتيل كبير العلماء في
البلاد وتعرضت منشاه طنز النوويه لاضرار
الجزئيه وفي العام نفسه تم ضرب منشات
الكراج
مسيرات اصفهان ضربت مصنع اسلحه حكوميه
الايرانيه في وسط مدينه اصفهان والذي
تصادف ايضا ان يكون مركزا لانتاج مسيرات
يقال انها ترسل الى القوات الروسيه في
اوكرانيا
تصريحات اوكرانيا لطهران بعد الهجوم باننا
حذرناكم ورد روسيا العنيف لدانه الهجوم
كلها اسباب تؤكد هذا التوجه وقبلها تحدث
اعلام امريكي عن ان اسرائيل هي من نفذت
الهجوم ومهما يكن من امر فانه هجوم اصفهان
يشكل نقطه تحول في المواجهه بين الغرب
وطهران بنقل المواجهه الى داخل ايران
نفسها التي تواجه احتجاجات ضد النظام الذي
فقد الحاضنه الشعبيه له
القضاء الايراني اصدر حكم على المدونه
الايرانيه سياج حقيقي وخطيبها امير محمد
احمدي حكما بالسجن 21 عاما اضافه الى
عقوبه اضافيه بعد نشر فيديو رقصهما في
ساحه ازادي بطهران وبحسب معلومات
الاستخبارات الايرانيه الفتاه والشاب
المذكورين في الاول من نوفمبر الماضي بعد
ضربهما واهنتهما واكدت التقارير ان القاضي
انهما خلال جلسه المحكمه وقد حرم من
اختيار محامي لهما محتاجون رددوا الشعارات
المناوبه الى النظام ايضا في ايران وضد
الفسيج خلال احتفال في طهران
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذه الاحتجاجات مشاهدينا المناوئه للنظام
انطلقت دفاعا عن رجال الدين السنه الذين
اعتقلتهم السلطات الامنيه في مدينه موكانا
الكرديه في محافظه اذربيجان الغربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نبقى في ايران والتي كشفت وسائل اعلام
ايرانيه ان المخرج مسعود كيميائي احدى
الشخصيات البارزه في السينما الايرانيه
منعه من السفر الى هولندا للمشاركه في
مهرجان روتردام السينمائي على خلفيه حركه
الاحتجاج التي اندلعت منذ سبتمبر الماضي
يذكر ان كمام في وقت سابق في مقطع فيديو
وقوفه الى جانب الشعب وذلك خلال التظاهرات
التي اندلعت بعد مقتل الشاب سامي اثناء
احتجامها وقد ادرم محتجون النار في تمثال
قاسم سليماني بالمولتو في مدينه كوبل
بمحافظه فارس الجنوب ايران
[موسيقى]
نشيل الى هذا العاج المشاهدين في ملف
تسليح اوكرانيا فقد اكد وزير الدفاع
النرويجي انه سيرسي الدبابات ليوبارد الى
اوكرانيا في نهايه مارس اذا تتسلم دبابات
ليوبارد من النرويج في نهايه مارس لنعود
الى ايران والتي اطلق فيها المحتاجون
شعارات ليليه في شارع شريعه في العاصمه
الايرانيه طهران
الموت للديكتاتور والموت للحرس الثوري
والموت للفسيج
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تعقب باستمرار ارتفاع الاسعار او اسعار
المواد الغذائيه تحديدا في ايران خلال
الشهر الماضي حذرت وسائل الاعلام من ازمه
سوء التغذيه في البلاد كما توقع برلمانيون
ايرانيون بارتفاع نسبه التضخم الى 60% او
اكثر في الاشهر المقبله
الجوع وسوء التغذيه نتيجه استمرار الغلاء
في ايران
احصاءات وزاره الصحه تظهر ان نحو 16% من
الاطفال دون سن السادسه في ايران يعانون
من سوء التغذيه
وان 800 الف طفل في سن النمو يواجهون نقصا
في الطاقه والمواد البروتينيه ونقصا في
المغذيات الدقيقه
[موسيقى]
برلمانيون توقع ارتفاع نسبه التضخم الى
اكثر من 60% بحلول مارس المقبل
مركز الاحصاء الايراني اكد ان معدل التضخم
السنوي في البلاد بلغ خلال الشهر الماضي
46.3%
خبراء اقتصاديون ونشطاء نقبيون قدروا ان
معدل التضخم الحقيقي في ايران اعلى بكثير
من احصاءات الحكومه
93 شخص مصرعهم في باكستان واصيب اكثر من
150 اخرين بجراحين في هجوم الانتحارين
استهدف بالامس مسجد في حي للشرطه
الباكستانيه في مدينه بشاور شمال غرب
باكستان ولم تعلن اي جهه مسؤوليتها عن
الهجوم حتى الان
بيشاور على موعد مع هجوم ارهابي دامن
مهاجم الانتحاريه تمكن من تجاوز الخطوط
الامنيه والتسلل الى حي للشرطه يضم مباني
سكنيه و مقر اداريه ويفجر نفسه وسط جموع
المصلين في مسجد الحي الرئيسي مخلفا عشرات
القتل والجرحى جدلهم من عناصر الشرطه فيما
وصلت فرق الانقاذ عمليات رفع الانقاذ املا
في العثور على نادين
[تصفيق]
الاحمر
على قيد الحياه وربما عدد اخر من القتلى
قد يستغرق اخراجه من تحت الانقاد ان
تتساعه
حركه طالبان باكستان مسؤوليتها عن الهجوم
الا ان الهجوم الذي اعتبر الاكثر دمويه من
دون نحو عام عاد الى الاذهان مشاهد الدماء
والدمار التي شهدتها البلاد خلال العقدين
السياسيين والعسكريين في وقت تعاني فيه
البلاد وانقساما سياسيا وازمه اقتصاديه
من بيوت الله واصابه العبارات
ونحن مستعدون للتضحيه لاجل ذلك
في وقت صعدت فيه جماعتنا ارهابيه
وانفصاليه هجماتها لعل من ابرزها حركه
طالبان باكستان التي اعلنت انسحابها من
هدنه هشه مع الحكومه شهرا نوفمبر الماضيه
تزامن ذلك مع شني اجهزه الامن عند تحملات
امنيه اسفرت عن مقتل واعتقال العشرات من
المسلحين
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه يرى مراقبون انه هجوم
بشاور يطرح تساؤلات عده حول نجاعه
الاجراءات الامنيه ويجدد على ان الملف
الامني يظل من ابرز التحديات التي تواجهها
الحكومات الباكستانيه المتعاقبه عبد
الرحمن العربيه
فرنسا على موعد مع تظاهرات ضد قرار رفع سن
التقاعد والشرطه تخشى من مواجهه عنيفه
احييكم من جديد فرنسا تستعد اليوم من جديد
من الاحتجاجات اليوم وذلك ضد اصلاح نظام
التقاعد الذي اقترحه الرئيس ايمانويل وذلك
على خلفيه بدء النقاش البرلماني حول نص
المشروع المثير للجدل وعقب مظاهرات
واضراوات واسعه شهدتها البلاد في الخميس
الاسود قبل نحو اسبوعين وافاد مصدر في
الشرطه قوات الامن تتوقع حشودا مماثله في
240 مظاهره في كل انحاء البلاد اليوم
بالاضافه الى توقف المواصلات والمدارس
وغيرها من الخدمه
من باريس ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حسين
قنيبر اهلا بك معنا حسين اذا المظاهرات
متوقعه ماذا لديك من معلومات حولها
بالفعل التظاهره الفارسيه اولا تظاهرات
العاصمه تنطلق عند الساعه الثانيه من بعد
الظهر بالتوقيت المحلي تنطلق من ساحه
الجمهوريه وتتواصل خمس ساعات على الاقل
وهي ستكون واحده من حوالي 200 تظاهره
ستوسع على كل انحاء البلاد في عدد كبير من
المدن الكبرى والمتوسطه والصغيره اذكر من
بين المدن الكبرى التي ستشهد تحركات واسعه
اليوم بالاضافه الى باريس طبعا اليوم
التلوث مارسيليا
سبور
ايضا هذه المدهون ستشهد تحرك دعت اليها
النقابات والاحزاب هي تحركات شعبيه نقابيه
حزبيه ستؤدي الى شلل كبير في قطاعات
الرئيسيه كما ذكرت فاطمه احتجاجا على رفع
سن التقاعد 62 عاما حاليا الى 64 عاما
الحكومه ترى ان السبيل الوحيد لتمويل نظام
التقاعد بعد ان ارتفع متوسط اعمار
الفرنسيين هو ان يمتد سن التقاعد من 62
عاما ان يرفع عامين اضافيين في ايطاليا سن
التقاعد 67 عاما في المانيا سنه التقاعد
اقلبي قليل من 66 عاما في اسبانيا هو خمسه
وستون عاما في فرنسا كان 60 عاما في عهد
الرئيس الاشتراك الاسبق الرئيس الراحل
فرانك ولكن الرئيس هيركزي الرئيس اليمني
رفعه الى 62 عاما واذا بالرئيس الامريكي
64 عاما شكرا لك من فارس مراسل العربيه
ومن باريس الى التوتر الفلسطينيه
الاسرائيليه المتساعد حيث حذرت جمعيات
الاسرائيليه تكافح العنف من تبعات القرار
الذي اصدره المجلس الوزاري المصغر في
حكومه اسرائيل للشؤون السياسيه والامنيه
وتم بموجبه منح تسهيلات جديده في اعطاء
التصاريح للمستوطنين بحمل السلاح وقالت ان
نتيجه هذا القرار ستقود الى وبال ستؤدي
الى بكاء لاجيال مديره تحالف مسدس على
الطاوله في المطبخ الذي يضم في صفوفه كل
الجمعيات المناهضه للتسلح اوضحت ان حكومه
سابقه بقياده بنيامين نتنياهو اتخذت
قرارات بمن حي تسهيلات في ترخيص السلاح
سنه 2018 وكانت النتيجه ارتفاع حوادث
العنف والقتل واضافت ان معطيات وزاره
الامن الداخلي لعام 20 21 تشير الى ان
اثني عشر شخصا انتحروا بواسطه سلاح مرخص
الى جانب سته عشره حاله انفلات رصاصه فيما
افاد تقرير نش صحيفه هارتس بان 86 من بين
100 بلده ترتفع فيها نسبه حامل السلاح هي
مستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه
يلتقي وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انسني
بلانكن الرئيس الفرنسي محمود عباس اليوم
في اطار جولته للشرق الاوسط زياره البلنك
ان تاتي مع محاولات خفض التصعيد في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه هذا وقد التقاء بلنكن
مع رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بيمين
نتنياهو حيث اكد على ضروره اتخاذ
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين خطوات الفوريه
للحد من التصعيد ووقفه مشددا على ان حل
الدولتين مهم لامن واستقرار المنطقه تقول
جرس الامبس مشاهدينا في عاجل يردنا ان
وزير الدفاع اسرائيل يمكن التهديدات التي
تواجه اسرائيل وخاصه ايران من القدس
التصعيد الحاصل بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين
والملف النووي الايراني شكلات طبق الساخنه
على مائده الحوار بين رئيس الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه وصانعي القرار في اسرائيل
كل ما بيسعها لمن ايران من امتلاك سلاح
النووي ونحن مصممون على تنفيذ هذه السياسه
في الوقت الذي نجح نتنياهو فيه لسنوات في
تهميش الموضوع الفلسطيني اعاده التصعيده
في ظل حكومه تشمل وزراء متطرفين الى
الواجهه وتاتي زياره لينكن لرام الله كما
مسؤولين امريكيين اخرين رساله لاسرائيل
بان توسيع دائره التطبيع بين اسرائيل ودول
المنطقه وحتى مواجهه ايران باتت مرتبطه
بعدم تدمير حل الدونتين
نحن مازلنا نؤمن ونسعى لتنفيذ رؤيه حل
الدولتين وكما قلت لرئيس الوزراء فان اي
شيء يبعدنا عن هذه الرؤيه هو بمفهومنا يمس
بامن اسرائيل على المدى البعيد
وبهويتنا كدوله يهوديه ديموقراطيه
اللافته ان زياره بلنك الى جانب مدير
السياحي الموجود في اسرائيل تزامنات مع
شني ثلاث غارات متفرقه على اهداف داخل
ايران وفي الاقليم طالت القدرات البالستيه
وسلاح المسيرات بعيدا عن الكلام
الدبلوماسيه الامريكي والاسرائيلي فان ارث
التوتر في العلاقه بين نتنياهو اداره يلقي
بظلاله على الحوار الامريكي الاسرائيلي مع
الحكومه الجديده ايضا واشنطن نقلت قلقها
مرتين مرتين من الملف الفلسطيني والانفجار
الحاصل ومره ثانيه من الملف الايراني
والخشيه من مفاجات الاسرائيليه زياد حلبي
العربيه القدس الغربيه
وحاول لقاء بلنكن بنظيره الاسرائيلي وزير
دفاع اسرائيلي يقول في هذا العاجل امامكم
على الشاشه انها واشنطن وتل ابيب متفقتان
على ضروره عدم امتلاك ايران سلاح النووي
وحول ذلك سنتحدث من القدس مع مراسل
العربيه زياد حلبي اهلا بك معي زياد اذا
ما ابرز ما جاء من تصريحات حول هذا اللقاء
من المسؤولين الامريكيين والاسرائيليين
[تصفيق]
ربما سلم
الاولويات في الطرح كان مغيرا لدى الطرفين
بمعنى بلنكن بدا مهتما بشكل خاص في ضروره
خفض سقف التصعيد ومنع انفجار الوضع على
الصعيد الميداني بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين بشكل كامل ما يجعل حلا
الدولتين امرا مستحيلا مستقبلا همم بالامر
الاخر الذي طرحه في اسرائيل هو نقل نوع من
رفض الولايات المتحده لما تقوم به الحكومه
اليمنيه لجهه اضعاف القضاء لان واشنطن قد
تجد صعوبه في الدفاع عن اسرائيل في البحفل
الدوليه الامر الثالث هو كان الملف النووي
مع ايران ومواجهه ايران ايضا
اقليميا عسكريا في المنطقه بهذا الموضوع
الخلافات اقل طبعا الترتيب الاسرائيلي هو
العكس تماما بمعنى التركيز في اسرائيل كان
ميران وايران وايران بهذا همم المعنى مع
وزير الدفاع اليوم ايضا طرح الملف النووي
الايراني وضروره التعاون همم واشنطن عمليا
تحذر تل ابيب من همم الاقدام على مفاجات
بدون التنسيق معها لسبب بسيط لان التابعات
ذلك قد تدفعه ايضا الولايات المتحده لجهه
امكان استهداف مصالحها في المنطقه
العسكريه والاخرى وبالتالي هناك محاوله
لجعل سقف التوقعات متوائما بين الجانبين
طبعا ينهي الشقه الاسرائيلي بلقاء برئيس
المعارضه قبل ان يتوجه الى رام الله للقاء
الرئيس الفلسطيني بدون ان تشك اللافت ربما
وهو مواكب الزياره اكثر من ما طرح في
الزياره بمعنى برينكن كان هنا وقبله وما
يزال ويليامبر رئيس مدير موجود في اسرائيل
ايضا قبل ذلك جاك سيلفا مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي زار المنطقه بالتزامن مع
ذلك ضربات على ايران عمليا بشكل متواتر
طبعا تم تنزيعات في محيط نتنياهو من
التسريبات الامريكيه السريعه هذه المره
عاده بعد اسبوع او اشهر يتم التسريب
للوشنطن بوست وما الى ذلك هذه المره خلال
اثنتان عشر ساعه من ضربه اصفهان جرت تسريب
واتهام اسرائيل عمليا ولهذا في محيط
نتنياهو يقولون بانه دائما يحذر من ان
الامريكيين يقومون بالتسريب حتى ان ذلك قد
يهدد ان اسرائيل وهنا ياتي امر الضربه
الاسرائيليه المستقله يقول نتنياهو وقال
ذلك علنا ايضا انه قد لا يخبر احدا بها
خشيه من ان يسربها الامريكيون يقصد
ادارهها شكرا من القدس مراسل العربيه
اعلنت المعارضه التركيه مشاهدينا عن وثيقه
السياسات المشتركه التي تتضمن خطه عملها
للمرحله القادمه
[موسيقى]
ما يعرف بالطاوله السداسيه وهي تجمع لسته
احزاب معارضه اطلقوا وثيقه السياسات
المشتركه وتتضمن خطه عمل الوزاره
والمؤسسات الحكوميه اذا حازت صناديق
الاقتراع الى جانب المعارضه
النظام البرلماني هو كلمه السر لحل ازمات
تركيا كما يقول معارضون رئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان الذي حاز صلاحيات واسعه في النظام
الرئاسي بناء عليه فان للرئيس ولايه
دستوريه واحده من سبع سنوات
بصلاحيات محدوده
ضمن عمليه الاصلاح
من خلال ادخال قانون ينص على انتخاب
الرئيس لولايه واحده فقط مدتها سبع سنوات
اصلاح الاقتصاد ومكافحه التضخم هو العنوان
الثاني في خطه المعارضه كسب ودي وقلوب
الناخبين هو ما تريده الاحزاب السته عبر
وعود كثيره لتحسين دخل الفرد السنوي وخفض
معدلات البطاله وتوفير فرص عمل جديده
يوتيوب
الى خانه واحده خلال عامين وننهي غلاء
المعيشه مع جهودنا في مكافحه التضخم سنزيد
معدل النمو باكثر من 5%
وثيقه المعارضه تضمنت وعودا باحترام حقوق
الانسان والحريات العامه ودعم قضايا
المراه لكن هذا كله مرتبط وفق ما يراه
كثير
بالاتفاق اولا على مرشح مشترك لمنافسه
اردوغان ونبذ الخلافات التي اخر ظهور
المرشح
تحاول المعارضه الاستفاده من الوضع
الاقتصادي المتردي في برنامجها الانتخابي
لذا ركزت على اصلاحها كاهم اولوياتها
وارفق ذلك باصلاح النظام السياسي والعوده
الى النظام البرلماني وتقييد مده الرئاسه
بفتره واحده غير قابله لتجديد زيدان زينجو
العربيه انقره
تصدر قرارا بمنح اللجوء التلقائي
للافغانيات
التزام امريكيا يتجدد في السؤال بالدفاع
عن كوريا الجنوبيه بالاسلحه التقليديه
قتل تفجير الانتحاري بمسجد في بيشاور الى
حيكم من جديد
تلقائيا للنساء الافغانيات وذلك قرارات
حركه طالبان ضد المراه والتي منها من
الدراسه الجامعيه والعمل واوضحت اللجنه
الدنيا
الافغانيات جاء بناء على معلومات تتعلق
بالتدهور المستمر لظروف عيش النساء
والفتيات في افغانستان وحدرت او حضر امين
عام منظمه كير الدوليه وهي منظمه شريكا
للمفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين حذرت ان تشديد عمل النساء في
افغانستان في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
وتقييد عملهم سيعرض حياه الكثيرين للخطر
وحتى للموت
لا تبين نوئا بقوتي يجب ان لا يكون هناك
اي غموض تقييد عمل المنظمات غير الحكوميه
بمنع النساء من تقديم الدعم المنقذ للحياه
لنساء اخريات سيكلف الارواح
جددت امين عام منظمه كير الدوليه على
انخفاض درجات الحراره في افغانستان لما
دون 29 درجه مئويه تحت الصفر يؤدي الى
مقتل الكثيرين هناك وان الوضع مروع وخصوصا
للنساء والاطفال
عاما الماضيه فاضي درجات الحراره الى 90
و20 درجه مئويه تحت الصفر لقد ادى هذا
البرد الى مقتل الكثيرين كما راينا في
الايام الماضيه بالنسبه للمجتمعات في جميع
انحاء افغانستان وخاصه بالنسبه للنساء
والاطفال فان الوضع مروع حقا ان القمع
مستمر لحقوق النساء والفتيات يجعل الوضع
بالنسبه لهن ولاسرتهن اسوا بكثير
اذا كان ذلك عن ليبيا اما عن افغانستان
اما في ليبيا افادت مصادر صحفيه ليبيه
بوقوع اشتباكات بين مجموعات مسلحه في محيط
مطار طرابلس وذكرت الصحيفه ان المجموعات
تابعه لوزاره الداخليه والدفاع في حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه التي يراسها عبد الحميد
الدبيبه وانها تريد السيطره على المنطقه
ككل كما اشارت قناه المسار الليبيه الى
وقوع اشتباكات عنيفه بالاسلحه في منطقه
الكريميه جنوب العاصمه طرابلس
اما في سياق اخر ونبقى في ليبيا هنا هدد
المجلس الاعلى لقبائل ليبيا باغلاق حقول
النفط والغاز في شرقي البلاد بعد اتفاق
حكومه الدببه مع ايطاليا مجلس القنابل
الوصفه الاتفاق مع روما بغير الشرعيه
مشيرا الى ان الاحتقان في الشارع الليبي
وصل الى درجه غير مسبوقه في الرباط
اول محادثات ثنائيه دبلوماسيه مع عبد الله
باتيلي رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده للدعمين
في ليبيا
بعد اول لقاء مع عبد الله باتيلي رئيسي
بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا اعلن
ناصر بوريطه وزير الخارجيه المغربي ان
الامم المتحده هي التي يمكنها حصريا ايجاد
حل في ليبيا بعيدا عن التدخلات الاجنبيه
المغرب
[موسيقى]
لرئيس بعثه الامم المتحده في ليبيا من
الرباط دعوه الى الليبيين من اجل الحوار
توقفي امريكي
الليبيون يعبرون عن هذا بطريقه قويه
ويريدون مؤسسات مستقره وذات شرعيه تفتح
الطريقه امام الازدهار في بلدهم
على البقاء دائما على مسافه واحده من
الاطراف فيما ترى بعثه الامم المتحده
للدعم في ليبيا ان الشرعيه في هذا البلد
لا يمكن حلها الا عبر انتخابات رئاسيه
وبرلمانيه بعثته الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا مع رئيسها الجديد تعتبر المغرب احد
الشركاء الدوليين في الملا في ليبيا فيما
الرباط ترى بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا مظله لما سارين اثنين احتضنهما
المغرب حول الا في الليبيه مسارس خيرات
ومسار بوزنيقه عادل الزبير العربيه الرباط
الى تونس والتي قال فيها الرئيس قيس سعيد
وزيري الزراعه والتربيه في وقت تعاني
البلاد من نقص بمنتجات اساسيه واضرابات
متفرقه في قطاع التعليم وسبق ان قال سعيد
مطلع يناير الحالي وزيره التجاره وتنميه
الصادرات ولم يذكر الرئيس التونسيه
الاسباب لكن الاقالات تاتي وسط ازمات
اقتصاديه وتوترات سياسيه وضعف نسبه
المشاركه في الانتخابات النيابيه
في اليمن مشاهدينا تستمر الميليشيات
الحوثيه في ممارسه انتهاكات جسيمه بحق
الاطفال في تعز ما تسبب باعاقات دائمه
للعشرات وذلك بحسب نشطاء حقوقيين اوضحوا
ايضا ان الاطفال في تعز يعانون القصوى
الحياه خصوصا الذين بشرت اطرافهم بقذائف
والغم ميليشيات الحوثيه
الى حيث يلعب الاطفال لكنهما يعودان الى
المنزل خائبين دون ان تلامس الكره قدم
احدهم على هذا الحال يوميا وبوجه تملاه
الحسره يتجرع الطفل بدر وشقيقه قسوه
الحياه منذ ان بطلت قدم بدر حوثيين بلغته
في حي المطار القديم غربي المدينه
[موسيقى]
ولا ولا تروح مع اصحابنا ولا ندخل الجنه
في المدنيين والاطفال بشكل خاص الاطفال
النساء
كده على المدينه مارست الميليشات الحوتيه
انتهاكات جسيمه بحق الاطفال تشور احصائيات
الى ان اكثر من 250 طفل في تعز يعانون من
الاعاقه نتيجه الحرب الحوتيه غالبيتهم لا
يزالون يخضعون لجلسات علاج طبيعي في مركز
الاطراف الصناعيه بمستشفى الثوره بتعز
تعتزم الينا الميليشيات الحوثيه ان تجعل
الكثير من ابناء المدينه هذه يعيشون في
اعاقه دائما خصوصا الاطفال والنساء الذين
تستهدفهم الى الاحياء السكنيه والطرقات
بالقضاء في والغرام الارضيه ال سعيد
العربيه تعز
الى العلاقه الامريكيه في كوريا الجنوبيه
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن قال
ان بلاده ملتزمه بالدفاع عن كوريا
الجنوبيه وباستخدام الاسلحه التقليديه
والنوويه وكذا على تعزيز المناورات
العسكريه المشتركه مع كوريا الجنوبيه
وتسهيل التنسيق العسكري الثلاثي ايضا مع
اليابان والسن قال ان بلاده تعملوا مع
كوريا الجنوبيه على تعزيز الحمايه مع
كوريا الشماليه بالتزامني مع تزايد قطرها
ومن جانبه صرح وزير الدفاع كوريا الجنوبيه
الحمايه من كوريا الشماليه
بحثنا اليوم انا ووزير الدفاع الامريكي
نتائج التحديات الامنيه المشتركه بما في
ذلك التهديدات النوويه والصاروخيه من قبل
كوريا الشماليه وكذلك بحثنا تطوير
التحالفات للمزيد من المسائل المستقبليه
في مالي حتى يوم من العام المقبل لا معنا
له في ظل الظروف الحاليه وخاصه مع عدم
قدره الجنود على مغادره معسكرهم وشرا الى
ان هذه المهمه بعدت مطيعه للوقت والمال
واعرب بالستوريس عن شكوكه بشان قدره
القوات الالمانيه على الوفاء بالتزاماتها
في اطار بعثه السلام في مالي والتي تواجه
ازمه مختلفه
في الختام دوما نذكر بالعناوين
وصل مخاوف اوكرانيه من انتقام من روسي
كبير بريطانيا تحذر من هجمات المتطوره في
دنيا
السلطات الاثريه تنصح مواطنها بعدم السفر
الى ايران بعد الهجوم على سفارتها في
طيران
الالتزام امريكي يتجدد في سول بالدفاع عن
كوريا الجنوبيه بالاسلحه التقليديه
والرابع النووي
السلطات الباكستانيه تعلن ارتفاعها حصيله
قتل التفجير الانتحاري في مسجد في بيشاور
الى 93
دمتم بخير
[موسيقى]